so passive failure we fail to teach kids
critical thinking correct active failure
is when you teach them stuff that is
actually wrong and makes things worse
well that's the situation we're in now
so if you indoctrinate the teachers you
don't need to indoctrinate the kids cuz
the teachers will take care of for you
when you don't learn the other side of
the issue you have an artificial
confidence in the things that you
believe the core Bedrock beliefs of this
ideology there's no other way to say it
they're so [__] stupid they're so
[__]
idiotic Peter bsian welcome back it's
been so long since we had you on the
show it's a pleasure it's great to have
you back and since we last had you on
you've been doing these amazing what you
call Street epistemology videos which
sounds fancy what you do is you get a
bunch of random people on the street and
you get them to start thinking about the
way they're thinking corre we did it
earlier with you today in the street
here in Westminster in front of the
Supreme Court right in front of the
Supreme Court no one in this Supreme
Court is kind of irrelevant in this
country in the US we don't give a [__]
but Street pestology very very
interesting some of your videos have
gone super viral with it because it's
fascinating to see how people respond to
H being made to think being challenged
on how they think being encouraged to
change their views about things with
presented with evidence what have you
learned from doing those videos oh boy
Reed and I have gone all around the
world and we've done this we're about
actually to go to Taiwan and New Zealand
we've gone to Puerto Rico we've been to
um Australia here in London we did them
well we've one of the things we've
learned is that people in London are
pretty chill about it they're pretty
relaxed in United States particularly on
college campuses students are looking
for a reason to be offended they want to
be offended uh i' I've learned so we we
have lines we put lines on the pavement
strongly disagree disagree slightly
disagree neutral and on the other side
and one of the biggest things I've
learned is that kind of reinforce what I
had already been thinking before is that
people will stand on a
line not based upon the evidence they
have but based upon some moral reason so
good people stand on this line I'm
standing on this line I'm a good person
good people should stand on this line I
should stand on this line I am standing
on this line I'm a good person that's
something so people kind of Outsource
their thinking to their tribe is that is
that kind of what you're saying um well
they find their tribe based upon a moral
reason to believe in it oh I see so
people will think about what it means to
them to be a good person and then
they'll align their confidence and a
belief so we we we'll throw it a claim
trans women should be in women's sports
the two-state solution is the best
solution and they'll stand on the line
that they think a moral person should
stand
on and it's a fascinating experience so
here's some of the other things that
I've learned one of the things and we
did it in our street epistemology
exercise when you have a claim if
somebody goes to the strongly disagree
and someone goes to the strongly agree
we will ask them to write down the
reasons that they think that the other
person has for holding that position and
we'll ask the person like we do to you
what's your best reason for believing
that what do you think his best reason
is for abortion to be legal in the first
trimester what is now Francis you have
to listen to see if she's correct take a
guess what you think his best reason is
I think it's going to be something about
um how um bodily autonomy for
women bodily autonomy for women is it
bodily autonomy for women don't don't
say what it is uh sort of yeah kind of
sort of or yeah yeah uh is it bod
autonomy yes it is bodily autonomy yeah
okay don't show him what do you think
her best reason is for being against
abortion in the first trimester it's a
killing of of innocent life is he
correct uh to a certain
extent
uh yeah I think that's pretty okay so
this is ex excellent so you understand
his
argument so turn around show it to
him you not agree with it but you
understand it I understand it yeah and
do you understand not agree okay I'm
going to grab
these what would it take you yeah what
would either she have to tell you or you
have to learn to move you to the
agree I'm going to ask you the same
question but to the disagree one one one
mat just one I I don't think I can and
because I believe sorry I forgot your
name Isabelle I believe Isabel's
position is fundamentally an absolutist
position which is and maybe I don't know
this but which is that it should always
be if a child if there is if a child if
there is a child in the womb or however
you want to classify it it should always
be brought to you there should be there
is no excuse or no reason for abortion
ever
so so what is preventing you from moving
to the agree what what what piece of
information and again I'm going to ask
you the exact same questions yeah
so okay I'm going to you first I'm going
to you first so what would you have to
learn to move you to the
disagree nothing because I've already
looked into the subject and I know human
life begins at conception and I know
that every human life has value okay
what would you you say to someone on
that end who is unwilling to
move I think it would be worth looking
at the impact of abortion on women
because I think um often that position
and and I don't mean to make obviously
any judgments about sorry I forgot your
name again Francis francis's um position
I wish I only know the statement is's
written on that board but I know a lot
of people who I have discussed abortion
with who say that they support abortion
think they're doing it to help women um
and I work very closely with post
abortive organizations and I realiz that
actually um abortion doesn't really help
women um it doesn't solve the initial
problems that they've got it can
actually create much larger problems to
take the life of your child doesn't
solve your problems if somebody is
standing on that
line and they are unwilling to move does
it strike you that the person now we
don't forget about Francis yeah does it
strike you that the person is an
extremist uh it you'd have to qu
quantify what what exactly unwilling to
change one's mind independent of the
evidence um I don't know that he's
unwilling to change it dependent on
evidence are you willing to change your
mind on the basis of evidence to move to
the agree yeah over this yeah there's
always if there is something new that
has been presented which I have not
thought about I have not considered then
absolutely so you just don't know what
the evidence is yeah so maybe but I have
never heard a good reason why a
14-year-old who is a victim of rape and
has a child should be forced to carry
that that child who is should be forced
to give birth to that
child are you willing to change your
mind about abortion in the first
trimester uh if a new piece of evidence
comes along the challenge is a
fundamental assumption you have that
would be the equivalent of asking me
whether I would change my mind about
killing another human innocent human
being because that's essentially what it
is nothing can make me think killing
human beings is a way to solve our
problems what if someone could show you
that life didn't begin at conception
would you change your mind but I know it
does I've looked into it long and hard
and I quite definitely know it
does okay when we did it in the Israeli
Palestinian conflict people couldn't
guess the best reason that the they
couldn't guess any reason that the that
the people had for it so there's such a
disconnect there it's not even that it's
incommensurable it's a that people don't
even understand why someone would hold
the belief what do you think this tells
us about Society more broadly that the
educational system has failed people
that um
we it's complicated because we know that
there are simple mechanisms that you can
use to help people think more clearly
and critically but we're not using those
method and they're free I mean anybody
can access them they're totally free and
we're not using them so I think that
some of it is at least some of it is
that the institutions have become
ideology Mills to replicate the dominant
moral ideology and do you not not think
as well that it might be that people
simply don't think about these things in
any great depth or detail because
they've got lives etc etc if you don't
think about something in any detail then
you should stand on the neutral line but
they don't they go to one extreme
they'll go and strongly agree or even
the agree so they they haven't
appropriately
calibrated the confidence in their
belief to the evidence so they've
extended the confidence in the belief
beyond the warrant of the evidence do
you think as well that the more
contentious the issue the more that you
are pulled to the strongly agree or the
strongly disagree because the more
contentious an issue the more likely it
is if that you are seen to be immoral if
you don't take the strongly agree or
strongly disagree position no I don't I
don't I don't think so but what I do
think is that there's intrinsic
selection bias so only certain people
who hold certain beliefs will come to
the line in the first place what I would
love if I had a magic wand and could
wave it is I would love to be in
situated in such that I could have all
the people come to the lines who would
normally never go you know we thought
about giving people Starbucks cards or
something but that would that also
creates perverse incentives yeah yeah
and you don't you don't want that so but
there is no way that I know of maybe I I
think it's probably impossible to get
people to play the game the exercise who
would not not play it that's the the
real problem is that some people won't
engage with ideas and have you found uh
any particular differences because you
talk about the education system failing
yeah uh the and it can fail in different
ways can't it one I think what you
initially were talking about is that uh
it fails to teach people critical
thinking is that kind of what you meant
or did I misread that yeah it fails to
so let's just ambigu that let's break
that down it fails to do a few things
it's kind of okay at teaching them skill
sets inference evaluation
explanation it's an abject failure
teaching them
dispositions tell tell us what all those
things mean because so there the the the
the famous there's an American
philosophical Association Deli report
it's kind of like
a it it's not without its problems it
was from 19991 it's kind of like the
definition of the ideal critical thinker
and yeah it's kind of written the way a
committee would write it but it's the
best we have today it's not perfect it's
probably revisable at some point point
but it breaks critical thinking down
into a skill set into an attitudinal
disposition the skill set it's fairly
easy to teach people basic skills in
about 20 hours you if you really cram it
through you could probably teach it in
15 maybe maybe 10 depending on the
people the students but the dispositions
are the hard things to cultivate for
example being trustful of reason being
willing to revise your beliefs I think
that's the most important one personally
are you willing to revise your beliefs
and the problem is that if you have it's
easy to test one of the reasons we teach
the skill set in school is it's easy to
test you know you you you can it lends
itself to multiple choice but you can't
really test a disposition you can test
if someone can identify a flaw in
reasoning or a fallacy but the
dispositions are difficult but here's
the the thing that I find absolutely
fascinating if you H have the skill set
but don't have the disposition you're
actually going to make epistemic
situation or your knowledge situation
worse yes so you you the the most
important thing is the disposition and
there are things like the California
critical thinking disposition inventory
where where we can kind of test that but
people can cheat it and game it and lie
about it but you can't really test a dis
you can't really give someone a
disposition you can tell them why they
should be willing to revise their belief
one of the ways that I always try to get
around that is if someone says if I ask
them a question and they say I don't
know like we did today I say that's a
great answer that's always a good answer
I don't know it's a great answer and
when I'm ask a question if I don't know
I will both change my mat or say I don't
know so I'll try to model those
behaviors for other people but the
dispositional aspect of critical
thinking is absolutely indispensable to
everything to participation in life in a
in a civil Civic Society to having a
reflective inner life there's literally
no domain in which that does not improve
and how do you teach people critical
thinking you said in 15 hours is there
some key Concepts it's pretty much in
every textbook you can think of what how
to be less wrong more often so how to
identify a fallacy so look we have two
things that we want to do we want to
believe more true things and believe
fewer false things but often those are
in conflict with one another so what we
do is we one of the things you can do is
teach this is a fallacy and and there
are names of fallacies add homonym redu
you adum Etc there are names of
fallacies but people will forget the
names but what I always try to do when I
was teaching is give them a concept of
like can you explain in plain English
what is the problem like what's the
problem here and they'll remember that
sometimes for a lifetime if you if
that's bundled with the idea of an
appeal to self-interest like your life
will be better your human flourishing
your community your relationships
everything will be better if you can be
less wrong more often coming back to the
education question that I asked you I
what I was trying to get at is there's a
kind of negative failure and then
there's a passive failure and active
failure so passive failure we fail to
teach kids critical thinking correct
active failure is when you teach them
stuff that is actually wrong and makes
things worse well that's the situation
we're in now with that's why I was
asking yeah so we're in a situation
which we have widescale organizational
capture that's in service to a moral
Orthodoxy a dominant ideology it goes by
many names um maet Noah's regressive
leftism the successor ideology Helen
pluckrose from the island here critical
social justice but the idea is that
there's a suite of propositions into
which one must assert to be to be
educated and the goal of the educator is
to help students develop what the
Brazilian educator PR F says a critical
Consciousness so you want to develop the
tools by which you can
find oppression everywhere op racial
oppression gender oppression sexual
oppression it's
sede moved off somewhat from economic or
maybe considerably it's Bartered really
identity politics for economic VAR and
how does that show up when you do these
experiments with with college students
oh it's completely conspicuous so people
will so here's here's the one of the
rubs when
your Ed particularly an educational
institution is held hostage to an
ideology almost invariably though not
invariably Christian apologetics is is
the exception to this you don't learn
the other side of the issue and so you
when you don't learn the other side of
the issue you have an artificial
confidence in the things that you
believe you inflate your confidence well
beyond the warrant to the the evidence
and that's co-terminus with the idea
that that you have to make up that slack
somehow you have to be offended you have
to have a microaggression you have to
complain to an authority figure but it's
a catastrophic failure for what for what
we're doing as Educators to children
we're teaching them we kind of giving
them this this critical Consciousness so
that they can identify and remediate
oppression but what we're not doing is
helping them value what's true we're not
telling them well here are other
Alternatives or here are other points of
view and you really have to have that
component so you you can your
epistemology should always precede
everything else like why you're doing
something how you know what you know is
always the first question and then once
you figure that out then you can go on
to think about how you should the
socrates's question how should we live
our lives what's a moral life are some
types of lives better than other can a
man be unjust towards himself that's
cons question but once you figure out
how you know what you know other things
within that epistemological framework
will follow your metaphysics in other
words what you think is this the natural
realm all there is or is there a
supernatural realm or what happens to me
after I die or will I go to hell or how
should I be kind or what role should
compassion play in my life so Pete how
do these kids engage with with the
exercise but you know the ones who comes
from these captured institutions as you
put it um
unre how do they think my my first
reaction is to say somewhat
unreflectively again I I do want to
stress that there is a selection bias
for people who come to the line so like
today those people who are at the trans
tell people tell people in more DET okay
so so we we we we might include a clip
but we might not be able to so okay so
our friend Luke went out and tried to
find people and there was a trans rally
around the corner and people were in
these full masks if memory serves me
correctly and I invited them to do the
exercise with us and I said you will get
more people correct me if I'm wrong in
this you'll get more people in 20 or 30
minutes doing this than you would if you
stood on that street corner literally
for a decade eight hours a day it's
YouTube it's just it's a vehicle now we
from our combined platforms we do that
and they were having absolutely none of
it they were having none of it and one
of the reason they were having none of
it for multiple reasons but one of the
reasons they were having none of it is
because
they have not been socratically trained
they have not been trained to defend
their ideas they've only been it's kind
of like a Catholic catechism or Marxist
ideological training they've been taught
that certain propositions are true and
they haven't really even been been
taught how to defend those so they don't
know the other side of a of a position
and if you don't know the other side of
a position you can't
argue you can't rebut the arguments that
you know right it's not it's literally
not possible that coupled with the idea
that they believe that intrinsic in
dialogue itself is some kind of
hierarchical power relations which
support white white dominance or white
white supremacy or something that's
completely insane and do they do they
say this when they're actually doing the
exercise when they come to their
justifications or or they try to rebut a
particular argument is it as avert as
that yeah some some people will either
be explicit about it or some people will
beat around the bush about it but
there's no question at all that most of
these people I would say the vast
majority and I'll I want to specify this
because this is important of us College
age kids most of whom are on college
campuses do not know the other side of
the position they have never even heard
it so even in an educational institution
as prestigious as Harvard or no
especially in an educational institution
as prestigious as Harvard so they have
never been told the other side of the
argument they've never been shown it
they've never had it explained to them
correct and in fact if you look at Greg
lov's
F that Harvard has among the worst um um
rankings for college free speech I just
wrote I wrote the forward about a year
ago to Rajiv mra's book he's an Indian
public intellectual and he really really
explains that in that
book the um the if you will to borrow a
turn for hedg monic the the the mono
thinking the mono culture that's created
and what I mean to me that is awful
because what you're essentially saying
is these institutions aren't fit for
purpose because the purpose of this
institution is to educate but they're
not doing that they're indoctrinating
well okay so fit for purpose they're fit
for the purpose of the ideologues who
run the in
so for their purpose they're discharging
exactly what their mission should be but
the problem with it is that once you
Veer from the truth once you stop
valuing what's true you're like the
horse that rides off furiously in all
directions any conclusion that you'd
want to forward is itself arbitrary it's
the result of either some kind of
capricious external force or some kind
of like my my buddy fasel alar was
telling me that um many countries a
cutter and other countries in Oman are
funneling in BLM propaganda and and
funding it and pushing it into the
United States so you're you become held
hostage to exogenous or external forces
and what happens when people like that
do participate in these experiments
because I you're very good at being
neutral but you're also very good at
pursuing The Logical conclusions of what
people say and presenting them with
challenges and so on and I imagine that
quite quick that world view starts to
unravel when it's challenged by someone
like you we'll get you back to the
interview in a minute but first let me
recommend an incredible alternative to
coffee that will give you that all day
energy without the Jitters in a
delicious hot drink mud water is made
with four functional mushrooms don't
make things out of dysfunctional
mushrooms and only a fraction of the
cathine you'll find in a cup of coffee
so you'll get that natural energy
without the crash each ingredient was
added for a purpose cacao and chai for a
hint of caffeine and hot chocolate like
Flavor Lion Man for Focus cceps to
promote Natural Energy and both Chara
and RI to support a healthy immune
system it's quality stuff and tastes
like caca and chai had a baby why you'd
want to drink a baby is anyone's guess
but there we are plus it's Whole 30
approved 100% USDA certified organic
non-GMO glutenfree vegan and kosher so
not only does it taste great you can
also give it to your woke mates right
now you can save $20 plus get a free
sample of creamer and a free fro by
going to the link in the description
below or heading to
mwr.com
trigonometry that's
mud
wt.com
trigonometry to save $20 on your
subscription and claim your freebies and
now back to the
show how do they react once they're
forced to confront the side of the
argument that they've never been exposed
to well let's take a step back from that
and say how they how how ought a sane
person to react a sane rational person
who wants who's self-interested that's
the other thing self-interested would
want to align their beliefs with reality
they would want to tether the things
that they believe to they'd want to have
some kind of linguistic hook that hooks
to something that's real that's not true
though mate that's not true at all
because if you're self-interested you're
interested in the opinion of your tribe
because your self-interest is linked to
how your tribe sees you right yeah so so
there's more okay so we can let's go
down that this is a rabbit hole but
let's go down it as I wrote in my last
book how to have impossible
conversations the only thing people want
more than to know what's true is to
belong yes so when you start questioning
someone's belonging in in in other words
their sense of tribe to use that word um
one of the consequences of that is that
you could sever their relationship with
their families their friends you know
Jehovah's Witnesses call it de def
fellowshipping uh um you know
Scientologist call you know they call
them squirrels people who don't agree
actually there even something in
Klingons have something from stord but
anyway but but the idea is that that
belonging is a hook so they could do
these Street epistemological exercises
and then go back into their communities
and ask their quote unquote you know
lead church leaders whatever leaders
whatever particular flavor or sect they
happen to belong what is the answer to
this like what should I say my argument
in that case would be even then they'd
be better off than that they didn't
participate because they would know that
there's some alternative they would know
that there's something out there that
that may give them pause or may give
them the gift of Doubt see I would push
back again on that I think they actually
might know that but they are so
inculcated within this particular type
of thinking and this group and
particularly P when when you're young
your friends are everything right so
you're going to be what a 23 year old
kid who's going to stand up against his
mates and God what I disagree with all
of you and the way you see the world and
the way we've brought up to believe that
this particular side is evil in white
supremacy that is a very rare type of
person I will answer that as well Pete
that we've had people on the show where
we've ask them a question and I can
literally see them in their head going
to where the question is obviously going
to take them and get uncomfortable and
shut down the conversation okay this is
I'm so happy you guys said this is so
important if we want to bring about the
kind of society that leads to our
flourishing the ant the older I get the
more completely convinced I become that
the way to do that is is to not just
tell people that for example revising
your belief when they hear it it shuts
down not tell them that you know You' be
better off but convince people that
changing their mind on the basis of
evidence reason and evidence is a good
thing to do it is a moral thing to do it
is morally responsible to change your
your your mind when presented with
something and so there's a famous thing
from Mormons about doubting your doubt
mhm this idea that you should doubt your
doubt because it makes you a better
person so if you want to promulgate or
promote certain values in the
society the best way to do that is
through a moral means other than of
course kind of create a f fascist
architecture or some kind of overarching
um institutionalization of principles
but if you want those to be based upon
something ideally that's that's has a
staying power and is sustainable then
you would link those to something moral
a moral something that has a moral
veilance to it it's a good idea to
change your mind it's a good idea to be
trustful of reason it's a good idea to
listen to people and there's also the
other element of it and I'm going to be
honest with my experience I yeah I loved
it it was great it was uncomfortable oh
when we did the exercise yeah it is
uncomfortable you know all of a sudden
you've got a mic in your hand or you're
miked up and you being asked to justify
your opinion you suddenly realize H I'm
not actually sure about this and then
you're being asked to check and then
you've also got someone who's
challenging your opinion right and we
have been we have brought up our kids
and you know this better than anyone to
and we've taught them that discomfort is
bad and any form of discomfort should be
avoided corre correct so having your
opinion challenged being involved in a
debate is challenging it's uncomfortable
yeah being asked to change your opinion
is even more uncomfortable yeah and I'm
going to use everything you just said to
forward the point that I just made if we
can help people understand that being
uncomfortable isn't necessarily an
intrinsic good but it's a byproduct of
of what happens when you examine your
ideas and when you live an examined life
being uncomfortable it's okay to be
uncomfortable right and there are
different degrees I mean if if you
wanted to demarcate a reasonable some
reason to be uncomfortable it would be
this
if
somebody if somebody says something that
Attacks An immutable property of you
your height my hair color um uh those
that would be off limits but ideas
people deserve dignity ideas don't
deserve dignity so people we need to
create these cultures in which we value
dialogue we value discourse and we let
people know it's okay to be
uncomfortable if you're engaging in in
wrestling with ideas Rogan said
something the last time he had us on his
show actually about this he said the
reason that I am willing to listen to
people and debate in good faith and
discuss things in good faith is I don't
conflate my ideas with my identity
correct and that to me is a distinction
that it feels like uh has been eroded in
my lifetime a hell of a lot where people
now are so attached to things that they
believe it's part of their identity and
then of course they can't change their
opinion because then it's not ideas that
are under threat it's you yeah and I'll
take take that a step further we've
institutionalized that you know say oh
you're uncomfortable you go to the
diversity office or you're uncomfortable
you call the bias response team and file
anonymous complaint or you're
uncomfortable like you you also bypass
the traditional you know we don't go to
the teacher we go to the diversity board
we go to the dean we go to the so we've
T we've taught people that instead of
having a self-reliance and a resilience
they
can I don't know go to you know there is
no exculpation from this whole thing
there's no kind of removal somebody has
to be held guilty for the offense and
I'm glad you said we've taught people
because I think it's tempting sometimes
for people like us to be like oh look at
these stupid college kids oh they're so
dumb oh they're so this oh they're so
that but they weren't born that way no
they're not dumb at all they've just
been indoctrinated and by our generation
and
yours I'm going to be more specific than
that that and yours as if our generation
is different I'm going years I'm going
let I'm gonna let let that uh the the
okay all right uh the the the other
thing that almost nobody talks about
which we should talk about and I really
wish we talked about it more is how that
what's the Genesis of that like how does
that metastasize in society and one of
the way ways again nobody is talking
about that virtually nobody is through
colleges of education so you you can't
just teach in a in a a high school or a
school you have to go through through
you have to get a certificate and these
certificates are basically
indoctrination Mills they power of fies
indoctrination Mills there ways that
we've modified piggy backing off what we
said before we've modified the purpose
of Education from we've actually almost
done more than modified it but U from a
truth-based centered education to the
alleviation of Oppression and we've
taught you don't need to teach kind of
like the Amway of it do you get the
reference am do you have Amway okay
forget about that but it's kind it's
like a multi-tier marketing scheme okay
okay so if you can teach
teachers if you can indoctrinate
teachers or teach teachers in a way to
think particularly and we can go into
this if you want a pedagogical practice
or which is is not Socratic it's not
challenging it's not questioning it's
not helping people to develop their
ideas in a kind of cleaning a clear
clean and meaningful way but if you can
teach teachers this then you can
literally indoctrinate generations of
people and then once those kids who have
been indoctrinated get to College well
they've already been indoctrinated right
so if you indoctrinate the teachers you
don't need to indoctrinate the kids
because the teachers will take care of
it for you correct and that's why one of
the things that we need to do is we need
to change the way that we CER teachers
fundamentally change but we can't change
the way we certify teachers because
there's educational rot in our in our
institutions so we're in a very
difficult position we're left with
either attempting to reform the
institutions which is virtually
impossible because people have tenure
they have jobs for life or we have to
build new institutions I personally am a
fan of the latter but I'm not going to
be polyan about it I understand that
this is not going to come overnight and
I also understand to maintain any kind
of economic competitiveness
it's it's probably not the best idea to
rip down your institutions your legacy
your academic institutions your maybe
your media might be a good idea but even
then you
have even then you're it's the the road
is dark and seny and fraught with danger
I mean this is not something that you
want to do a process by by which you
just want to capriciously may I just on
this point just to finish
um this is where I'm going to sound very
Li libertarian in a way that broadly I'm
not but it seems to me like this is
where the lack of competition in
education is a massive problem because
if you had a competitive educational
sector then parents will be able to
choose number one in a way that is more
difficult now because you really have to
cough up a lot of money to be able to
send your kids to to a different type of
school but also it would the results
would be borne out in the outcomes for
the children so if you go to a school
where someone like you is teaching
you're going to have a very different
set of Life outcomes correct but we
don't have that BEC certainly in this
country because it's like either you pay
50 Grand a year or chances are your
child is going to there are some
exceptions but broadly speaking your
child is going to go to a school where
they're going to get this [__] correct
so we have consigned a generation of
people a generation of students the
generation of the next leaders of our
countries we've consigned
them to not be reflective to not think
clearly and critically to not develop
the dispositions necessary to economic
prosperity to understand why our
institutions are the way we are you know
would Ronald Reagan's famous quotation
freedom is only one generation away from
being extinguished so we have created a
situation in which the core pillars and
values of the West question tradition
are under a sustained and prolonged
attack as Florence Reed from unheard
said we are living through a time that
is uniquely stupid this is a uniquely
stupid time in human history I mean the
the aidic pronouncements or even if you
don't even think about it that way the
core Bedrock beliefs of this
ideology are there's no other way to say
it they're so [__] stupid they're so
[__] [__] idiotic you know every
disparity and outcome is due to the
system that's just demonstrably false
every dispar every racial disparity for
example is due to the system and as
Helen pluckrose says and I just love
this I think it's amazing you can have a
conspiracy without any conspirators
nobody can be racist but the whole
system is somehow but yet when you parse
it out when you look at it in a more
granular granular way and you look at
for example success rates of people who
have historically been discriminated
against like I don't um Indians from
India east east Asians cold climate
agents etc those disparities don't pan
out so then you have to do mental
gymnastic to try to make the ideology
work and the reason that the ideology
works is as someone who used to work in
the system is because we don't train
kids like you say to critically think
what we do is we feed them information
they process information they go to an
exam they regurgitate information so
actually you're not it's and the way I
describe it is like this so the way that
we used to I always thought I wasn't
particularly good at maths yeah but the
reason was I was never taught maths I
was just taught a process and when all
you do and all you're taught is a
process then you don't actually
understand maths cuz you're just doing a
pattern okay it's only when you were
taught mathematics do you actually
understand it and then you are then able
to apply it properly okay so we have two
additional components or features that
are necessary to understand this the
first one is
that the reason that kids are taught
with they're taught now without going
into details is because of a moral
component right so we teach the kids
this about oppression about systemic
discrimination about disparities because
this is a it is a moral good this is
what we need to be a just e Equitable
haven't used that word yet Equitable
Society so that's one key component of
it and I can't remember where I was
going but there's also and whilst you
think about this there's another
component of it which is what in my
experience I saw which is schools are no
longer about education they're glorified
data factories yeah which are then kids
are then shunted through which they then
do these exams and then the government
is able to justify their position and
say look what a great job we're doing 70
or 92% or whatever it is percentage wise
of kids are are good at grammar right
but they're taught to pass a test which
is just learning and then
regurgitation they they can't write
better they're not more articulate they
can't construct a sentence yeah so how
do we so the problem has been analyzed
to death we all know it's a problem
we've kind of grafted these grafted
these moral values onto eggs and systems
that we have and then the question is
what do you do about it right like we
know that this is a catastrophe we know
that our institutions are under
sustained attack we we know that the
that the we're pretty familiar with the
data of the people who hold the ideology
again to mention Greg lukanov and Ricky
schlatt's book I I just finished it
about a
cancellation um we know that there are
manifestations of this problem what do
we do about it is the question well I
mean one of the things we've just disc
discussed which is you have to have
alternative structures for Education uh
I we were just in Austin and everyone
you talk to in Austin has just moved to
Austin mhm and one of the things they
they're all saying is like well look the
American education system is [__]
totally but at least in Austin I feel
like there's 20 of us and we can pull
together and do like homeschooling for
all our kids together or you know
there's charter schools in America there
are grammar SCH schools here in the UK
there's other there there's other kinds
of options Katherine bbal Singh who's a
frequent guest on our show her school
isn't teaching kids any of this crap
right so part of it has got to be
alternative
education I would say yeah part part of
it is you have to build new things I I
see no other way around it and in the
media space actually I think it's one of
the areas where the push back has been
the most
successful um and it's maybe that's
because it's the easiest place to do it
you need you know four cameras a few
mics and and a room and you you can
actually start to change the media
conversation education obviously much
bigger project um there are a few you
know there's Ry College there's r r yeah
and sa University of Austin in Austin
yeah um is is that it well there are
others that are emerging right now but
those are the two main competitors to
the system so slight slight progress in
education a bit more progress in Media
yeah yeah and we would really need to
break down there's an architecture in
place like substack for alternative
media there's much less so for
Educational Systems or educational in
various educational Arenas but we would
also need to take a look at like what
should they teach what should their
mission be what pedagogy should they use
what forms of Engagement of
students the these are I don't think
they're particularly difficult
questions but when the whole discourse
has been hijacked for so long now for a
decade they become it just puts the
conversation in hard mode they become
more difficult to answer and look this
is me going to sound very left wi but I
think this government in intervention
there should be there should be
inspectors and they should go and
inspect but the inspectors themselves
participate in the ideology the whole
system is corrupt the inspectors are
there to make sure they're being told
non that's the problem okay
so you shoot them yeah you
to there's a lot of teachers who would
agree with you on that fact but then
introduce something maybe a new type of
Inspector or something along those but
the people introducing the inspectors
are also part of this world the
institution is set up to replicate the
dominant ideology it is itself the
problem yeah but there are people who
don't believe in this ideology who
fundamentally disagree with it and
that's what you need to set up exact in
order that they and maybe it starts out
as an investigation just a government
investigation where they
go no let me just interject here what
you're saying is all true provided we
ever elected a government that had any
interest in doing that and seeing it
through and what we've seen repeatedly
by the way certainly in this country is
there are governments that were elected
and had ministers for Education Michael
go for example he wanted to take on the
educational blob I don't know if he did
it well I don't know if he did it badly
but what happened is he tried and then
he got sacked or resigned or whatever
right so there's also this other thing
which is uh this is a bigger step back
but we're in a position where
actually the Democracy isn't delivering
the results that the people are voting
for you can in this country we've had a
conservative government for 13 years now
they are not doing these things the it's
amazing like a government Minister will
write an article in the telegraph
complaining about about wokeness and I'm
like why don't you [__] fix it you're
elected you are the government but it's
not working right so this is the
conundrum which is why we're all doing
death by analysis because we're like we
can vote for people but they don't do
anything and so that's why I think it's
like homeschooling or bust cu no
institution is answerable to the people
anymore and martial arts I've actually
thought about this a lot because you
know you can have all these stupid ideas
but when you're doing a martial art or
you're doing a contact sport that goes
out the window cuz if you start going
into your own head you're going to get a
punch on the nose you're going to get
rolled over there's a reason for that
that I think is very profound in that in
certain martial arts there's a built-in
corrective mechanism and when you remove
the correct corrective mechanism crazy
starts to come in there's no way
to you you have to have a corrective
mechanism actually I published a paper
on this but you have to have a
corrective mechanism in what you do to
make sure that your ideas align with
reality and that's the problem like
we've said before the ideas don't align
with reality so there needs to be a
constant reinforcement with these kids
and young people that look you can have
all the intellectual masturbation you
want the reality is the reality well
that that brings us back to Street
epistemology Street epistemology is a
way to help people make their ideas
clear and all of these resources are
free they're they're for anybody can use
them and I'd highly encourage Educators
to use them exactly you don't need mats
like we have you can use tape or chalk
and then you can just ask kids to start
in the neutral line and ask them a claim
how confident you in that and then very
gently question uh question them and see
and and encourage them to move you could
go on the line first and then over time
maybe two or three sessions you you
stand on the line and you have kids do
that for you but let's come back to what
we were talking about which I think your
criticism is very fair and it's one I've
been making of our team whatever our
team is which is we keep talking about
what's not working what are we for right
so we've you asked the question what how
do we fix this and then we shouted at
you for five minutes with our ideas what
do you think we should do do you
remember the Canadian trucker protest in
2022 where thousands of Canadians came
out to protest Co restrictions and
vaccine mandates now these protests
lasted for weeks and the people out on
the streets needed money as any
Grassroots protest would so people set
up online crowdfunding campaigns which
raised millions of dollars it was
incredible but those campaigns were
closed down and the money didn't get to
the protesters because the Canadian
authorities started to criticize the
crowdfunding platforms ramping up
pressure on them to close the campaigns
the biggest crowdfunding platform the
one we've all heard of completely
capitulated to the demands now this is
where our partners give s go come in
they stepped in when the other platforms
backed off and raised millions of
dollars for the truckers when they were
criticized and dragged through the
Canadian courts Gib and go came out and
said they respect diverse views and
believe hope and freedom are values
worth fighting for this is why we're
proud to partner with them so if you
need to crowdfund for whatever means the
most to you then don't go to the big
Tech platforms go to give Sendo starting
a campaign on give send go is easy and
intuitive go to give send go.com today
that's gend go.com to start raising
money for whatever matters to you first
we have to build new things okay second
of all we have to move the overt 10
window we we have to change the way
that people think about what it means to
be uncomfortable what it means to change
your mind what it means to engage in
civil dialogue we have to start
listening to people more we have to
understand why someone believes what
they believe it's one one of uh quote
unquote rapaport's rules before you
offer any criticism make sure that you
absolutely understand so a very quick
technique that people can use for this
is once you have listened to someone and
you think you want know what they they
mean say let me put it on yourself the
burden of yourself let me see if I
understand this correct is this is this
correct and you repeat it back to them
that one little technique would avoid so
much confusion and it's a it's a way to
help people to understand each other and
that's the other thing is to seek not to
persuade this is Jurgen haras the German
philosopher's idea but to seek in in he
writes What's called the theory of
communicative action to seek to
understand we want to seek so I want to
try to understand why you believe this
and if I understand why you believe this
the likelihood that we could come to a
solution that's agreed upon or some kind
of a maybe maybe consensus wouldn't be
exactly the right word but some kind of
agreement about how to proceed is
greatly enhanced except what we saw
today m is that the ideology we are
concerned about is explicitly designed
to prevent that from happening 100%
correct it's explicitly circular and
exclusionary of the precisely of the
thing you're saying which is the
opportunity for discussion right so if
somebody doesn't adere to it so it's not
just that they don't adhere to the rules
of reason and rationality it's that
they've opted out of the system
altogether yes and the way that they
engage is to disrupt and dismantle quote
unquote the way that they engage is to
bring bullhorns into an auditorium the
way that they engage is to say that
you're rapist or a Nazi or get all their
friends to gang up on you on Twitter so
we we have many there there were
multiple multiple things I said there
and there are many ways to engage it but
first first and foremost we must not
seed to
lunatics there's no reason that we
should be held hostage to the demented
vagaries of people with whom we have
nothing what did what have substance do
they have to contribute to the
conversation if you want to come into
enter the conversation you want to say
something great if not there's no polite
or politic way to say this we're just
going to re relegate you to the Kitty
table you can go in there and you can
you you can do but lii has some
interesting stuff on this about um gray
cities blue cities and we saw we
listened to the P Peter T lecture the
other night and he
linked the idea of real estate
structural inequalities Etc to the
replication of the ideology to simplify
that just for people listening the idea
being the housing crisis causes wokeness
basically because young people are
locked out of a future they're locked
out of having a family and therefore
they are nihilistic and they don't see a
future and they do see and experience a
lot of inequality and therefore they're
angry and resentful and bitter and
unconstructive about life correct and
that was at the Roger scrutin lecture
that people can I'm I'm sure will be
released so we have to stop seating
moral ground we we we cannot listen to
people who scream and shout like there's
just if you want to present your
argument present it if not you go you
can go off in the corner like we we we
just cannot seed to we cannot continue
to be held hostage to the most
irrational people but this goes back to
my point about discomfort which is
something I wanted to delve into we as a
society and I am just as guilty of this
as anything as anyone else we are
looking to avoid discomfort and that
being the case you're going to avoid the
confrontation and then when things
happen when you get pylons you
capitulate yeah you you couldn't achieve
anything in your life without discomfort
exactly literally nothing you couldn't
build a business without discomfort you
couldn't build if people interested in
social media you couldn't build a social
media you couldn't be good at Jiu-Jitsu
you couldn't be good at skiing you you
couldn't do anything in which there is a
corrective mechanism you could for
example play air guitar right because
there's no lawful relationship between
you moving your fingers and a sound
coming out you could play Air basketball
like you could do something in which
there's no correc mechanism the moment
you attempt to tell people that it's a
good thing to remove
discomfort not not to go down this
rabbit but we attempted to do this by
saying that pain uh the the we we have
an almost entire generation that's
susceptible to opioid addiction because
we've told them it's like a fifth Vital
sign that we've attempted to remove all
kinds of all sources of discomfort phys
look that doesn't mean when you go to
the the dentist you shouldn't get
novacaine but I think we need to I think
you're right Francis I think we need to
rethink the idea of discomfort
and help people understand that is a
certain kind of virtue to endure a
degree of discomfort in order to achieve
something and you H what kind of Life do
you want to lead do you want to lead a
life in which you're not striving in
which you're not achieving in which
you're not trying in which you're either
so you find discomfort so dyspeptic or
you find it so you're so Avers to
discomfort that is a barrier to any
possibility that you could achieve
anything you simp cannot achieve
anything that's real if you spend your
life issuing discomfort and it's also
and this is the other problem linked to
discomfort which is going to link back
to what we just spoke about a second
ago we are uncomfortable about saying to
people you are behaving like a child if
you do not want to take part in the
discussion in your own words if you want
to scream and shout then you're going to
be on the Kitty table because we
experience that as confrontation okay so
I'm not I'm not uncomfortable with that
at all and I'm going to say I'm going to
suggest something to you if you speak
bluntly and honestly to people and you
tell them exactly what you just said
they will respect you more and not less
rather than a sniveling or I'm sorry or
for me oh you know you you go over there
and you you know do your own thing with
your wave your flag or wear your bandana
or what have you so so the the very idea
that people don't engage other people or
don't call people a [__] because
they think that they're going to I don't
know be mad at them or hurt their
feelings it's almost exactly the
opposite they will respect you more they
respect people who are forthright in
their speech they respect people who are
blunt and honest that doesn't mean have
to be rude but just be forth right in
your speech Pete let me ask you this
because I think this is at the core of
all of this can this be corrected
without a catastrophe because this is
why I've been concerned about all of
this from day one because ideologies
that are out of touch with reality cause
people to do things that are impractical
or dangerous and damaging which is where
I feel we are particularly in the west
we've undermined ourselves domestically
our foreign policy has been a disaster
in terms of signaling weakness which is
why in my opinion we're seeing many of
the things that we're now seeing uh
happening in the world however people
who are delusional in this way don't
generally tend to self-correct unless
there is something even more painful
than the discomfort of having to correct
their delusions so my question to you is
do you actually think this can be
corrected without a giant war or some
kind of you know something of that
nature I guess it depends on what you
how you Define catastrophy catastrophe
we've already had a catastrophe right
we're already in a catastrophe
of uh the legitimation crisis haras is
1973 piece we're already in in a crisis
in which people don't trust their
institutions they don't trust their
media they don't trust their the only
people but that's bearable the ordinary
person you go out there in the street
and you ask people you know the
legitimacy crisis the breakdown of ins
they don't know what the [__] you're
talking about yeah but they it's not
hitting them in the pocket it's not
hitting them in the but true but if you
ask them I can't speak to this this
Contex do you do you trust Congress in
the United States is an all time the
only people if you look at survey after
survey the only people individuals Trust
their own Physicians they don't trust
the medic point something else my point
is it's not painful enough for people to
care enough to actually do something it
makes you it makes you wonder doesn't it
what would happen if something real
actually happen What would happen I mean
we we have inculcated a sense of
fragility in people so and we've told
them it's actually a good thing to be
fragile yes it's a so can that get fixed
of course it can get fixed without an
actual catastrophe as in people dying on
Mass
there's no question it can but people
need to want to fix it right people need
to identify it as a problem but you're
dodging my point my point is exactly
this can people can people experience
the need to fix it without suffering
terrible consequences first no I wasn't
dodging the point I wasn't doging sorry
I didn't mean to be rude no no you can
be as rude as you want anything you can
say anything you want to me um no it
gets back to the point I made before
about what they value if they value not
doing that they can because it's like
the it's like leading the dog it's like
the leash right if they Place their
values ahead of if if they value being
resilient if they value tolerating a
certain amount of discomfort for
achievement if they value the right
things you can change it the problem is
and I don't mean this to beg the
question of being honest with you how do
we help people value the right things
well so okay let me rephrase cuz I think
what we're we're talking about the same
thing but talking past each other that's
exactly what I'm saying is is it
possible do we need that I don't is it
possible for people to no I hate to use
this term but to wake up yeah from the
delusions into which they've been
educated it's to without something so
uncomfortable that it overrides a
discomfort of having to let go of that
it's totally possible part of the
problem with waiting or expecting a or
having some catastrophe befall people is
that among the people who were already
susceptible to this they would say look
we didn't adhere to the ideology deeply
enough I mean they wouldn't explicitly
say that but you know we always knew we
were victims look now the system did
this to us the system got us in this war
the system caused Hamas to do whatever
what whatever it is so I don't I don't
think that the solution to the problem
is to either hope or wait for or expect
or anything some kind of catastrophe
because that might actually worsen the
situation I'm not hoping for a
catastrophe I'm fearful that that's the
only thing that will shake people up I
mean it might not Shake people up that's
the point I see what you're saying I
mean the Hamas attack on Israel I think
woke up a lot of people on the center
left in
particular are you asking no I'm making
a statement I mean I wrote a an article
for the Free Press I read that it was
excellent which is essentially my
assertion is there are a lot of people
who who that that shifted their
perspective right because they saw
things about their own side that that
were so expressed by the way and they
they were the same the same people
screaming about microaggressions and
someone asking where you from or you
know you've seen video after video of
people openly shouting at Jews because
there's nothing to do with Israel
nothing zero yeah the same the same
people and now fortunately people who
have been traditional philanthropists
are removing their money and you should
not be doing you want want to know what
you can do about this Spirit one of the
things you is you stop donating to your
alada they're simply not the same
schools you can stop donating to a
process that furthers this madness and
Pete before the interview you made a
statement about America being in the
hospice or on its way to the hospice
marching toward hospice Maring marching
towards hospice is this what you're
talking about or is there something
else I think this is a piece of it
I'm
look I don't like this I'm not I get no
joy of sitting here and tell telling you
that we the United States is marching to
at hospice I I don't see things I'm not
particularly Rosy might be one way to
put it we we have $33 trillion in debt
we're printing money like it's going on
a style evidently the best people the
system can produce are Donald Trump and
Joe Biden which I think will be nobody I
know wants that it's a to be again
extremely blunt with you I'm embarrassed
as an American I'm embarrassed as a US
citizen that those are the two people
we've
produced uh independent of what you
think of the particular policy positions
of anyone individual onethird of the
taxes collected last year went to pay
the interest on the debt people aren't
engaging substantive questions in any
sustained way our institutions that
suffer from wholesale ideological
capture particularly our educational
institutions the meritto meritocracy has
been undermined again you could look at
it if if you normed out if you looked at
SAT scores for example at Ivy League
schools over 51% of those students
should be Asians but they're not there
you want to know if there's systemic
discrimin yeah there is actually
systemic discrimination and it's we know
exactly who it's against Asians the same
people screaming for micro agant have no
problem with calling for the heads of
Jews I mean it's it's just and the these
people are educational administrators
they're professors they teachers again I
say this is It's kind of nucleation
point for a larger nuclear catastrophy
if you will we we know that people don't
trust their
institutions I just don't think that the
current system as we have it is
sustainable there are too many
geopolitical instabilities hot spots in
the world right now I don't think we're
we're having appetite for any I'm not
saying we ought to have an appetite for
foreign conflict but I think that we
need to have a serious conversation
about China Taiwan about Ukraine I think
we need to have a serious conversation
about a lot of things that where simply
we have removed the tools for people
that we know what those tools are for
how to have better conversations to for
how to speak to each other we're not
doing that you cannot solve a problem
unless you're willing to have be honest
and forthright and have an honest open
dialogue and discourse about it and if
you value that and we've lost that now
the question is will we get it back I
think we will what damage will have that
have done to our institutions our
Judiciary what damage will that have
done to trust or confidence in the
institutions um again it's just so
epically stupid I mean what are they
offering they offering Chaz what what is
the right I mean it's just it's so you
know Hamas knows what a woman is
everybody knows what a woman is I mean
it's just so we went from pretending to
know things we don't know to pretending
to not know things that everybody knows
I mean there's a whole lot of pretending
going on but that's not a uniquely
American phenomenon nor is it merely in
the angles spere it's spreads in it's a
neoc colonial export that's spread
through the world and so we're looking
at a pretty precarious perilous
geopolitical situation we're looking at
a country in which our citizens don't
know or fundamentally question the
American values they don't think that
the values of the country are worth
fighting for enlightenment principles PR
freedom of speech freedom of the press
freedom of assembly we have
demeaned the very principles that has
made our country not just great but a
shining City upon a hill and that is
where we stand right now we are stand we
stand with deficits that are crippling
us we're standing with nobody talking
about issues people being consumed by
woken or anti- wokeness when we have
substantive problems we have substantive
homeless problems my friend Michael
shellenberger good friend of mine he ran
for governor uh and one of the things
that he was going to do even a simple
thing like most people in West Coast in
East Coast cities will acknowledge that
homelessness is a problem they will
acknowledge that it's in fact when you
when you look at the data in California
in particular people rank that as one of
the top five problems but we're not
having an honest conversation in in San
Francisco Michael writes about shelter
first housing earned shelter first
housing earned we've had Mel a couple
times by the way when you say that
people aren't having an honest
conversation I we should also make clear
it's not just the left it's the right as
well right the right does this moronic
thing where they're like yeah we've got
money for you crine but we haven't got
it for the homeless it's not a money
problem it's an ideology problem yeah so
if if you want to talk about a criticism
of the right because I wasn't meaning
any of this as a CR I think often this
is framed as a Critic ISM from the right
or from the left like the trans issue
whereas it should be just what's the
evidence and if people on one side
happen to disagree then they need to
Marshall their evidence and show it
because I don't think it's I don't I
think casting it that way is a mistake
because people will be to use to borrow
your word people will be tribal and and
they won't actually look at what the
evidence for a position is well look I
don't want to finish on that uh low note
I think one of the ways that this can be
be influenced where they can be changed
there a different conversation is is um
I like I say I think in the media space
we actually have been extraordinarily
successful in C well you guys in
particular I don't just mean us there
are people way bigger than us I mean
look our politics are different to the
deli wise politics but when I see a
media organization of that size emerging
which challenges some of these
narratives I think that's very powerful
when I see Joe Rogan is the biggest show
in the world I think that's very
powerful when I and look what they how
they come for him too right but but the
thing is can't get him anymore that's
the thing that's reassuring to me like
this cancel culture stuff it works at
the lower levels but there are certain
levels at which it no longer works I
agree and Rogan is is spearheaded that
and there are other people who
spearheaded that and the fact that you
know two idiot comedians can build this
up to the point that it is now that to
me is also a reassuring sign and the
number of people who now listen to all
of those people in that ecosystem it's
quite significant and growing daily as
well the one thing I'm worried about is
Young gen the Young Generation the genas
the boys they are based as the kids now
say the girls are going Uber woke even
more and that disparity we know that
Jonathan Height's research has talked
about particularly the dangers of Tik
Tok and social media so that disparity
is going to be troubling but I do think
I do think brib was right that politics
is Downstream of culture yeah this is
culture and if more people are listening
to these kind of conversations with
amazing people like you who are offering
a a CR critical thinking about these
issues we're going to persuade some
people uh and that may be how we start
to unwind some of these things over time
and offer a better alternative so I hope
that's true and if it's not we'll have
World War I and all day U so Pete it's
been great having you back I thought we
were going to end on a positive night is
POS either everything is great or we're
all dead isn't that that's very Russian
yes we all did drink vodka but you know
what yeah a death in a nuclear
Armageddon in which we all die Qui is
much better than a slow painful you know
and loads of Civil War and all of that
kind of stuff just everybody dead
everybody happy anyway on that positive
note Pete as you know before we go to
locals where we uh have questions for
you from our supporters uh the question
we always ask at the end is is what's
your favorite type of nuclear
Holocaust a quick one there we go the
question is that wasn't as funny as you
told depressing depressing what should
we be talking about yeah baby I think
because I listen to your podcast
religiously if you will um I think it's
less what we should be talking about and
more how we should be talking about it
and I think we need to shift the
conversation instead of from particular
issue don't get me wrong it's important
but how do we engage people with whom we
disagree how do we listen better how do
we ask better questions so that if you
actually do want to persuade somebody
you'll be more successful than screaming
or not listening or not engaging and so
what we should be talking about is how
to engage people and what it would it
actually really means to understand
somebody's position and I would say that
it's maybe not something that we should
be talk talking about and it's more
something we should be modeling and
that's actually what we try to do the
way we have conversations including
recently loads of people on the show
with whom we fundamentally disagree but
we still give them the time we treat
them with respect we try to get to the
core of what they're saying that's what
that's always been our approach and I
think that's why every time we get like
new exposure in terms of like a big
media event or something happens where a
lot of people come to our Channel or
come to our
podcast the first thing they all say is
the one thing that distinguishes you
from most other media is that you listen
to your guest and you let them talk and
that is the first step actually for for
what you talking about so maybe it's
less about talking about and it's much
more about showing modeling and trying
to to be uh in that correct operate in
that way Pete awesome to have you back
thanks man everybody should be checking
out your street pestology videos because
they're just amazing and it also teaches
you how to think like Francis said you
know we are obviously in the space we
think a lot we think for a living
and yet you know we took something away
from that so it's really great wish you
all the the best success with that head
on over to locals where we ask Pete your
questions what is so appealing about
work that allowed it to take over
Academia is there a certain personality
type that is susceptible what trait
about yourself conferred immunity to
this way of thinking behaving that's a
great
think